thank you for the introduction does it
work yes so it's absurd we are in you
know professional lives we are active in
computational finance and and in
industrial mathematics but what I'm
going to speak about in the next 20
minutes or so is a kind of fun project
in our company namely that we are
developing a so-called density
functional theory called in in the more
firm language or in Mathematica don't be
frightened by the term I'll explain in a
minute what it is so in in a nutshell
what it allows you to do is to compute
all sorts of material properties from
very little knowledge basically from
just knowledge about basic quantum
mechanics and and natural constants that
win behind the whole endeavor is that we
would very much like to be able to solve
this equation this is Schrodinger's
equation as some of you might know and
well it basically contains well almost
all of chemistry it contains almost all
of material science which ranges from
steel production down to nanotechnology
which in itself contains well
semiconductor industry is a special case
it would tell you all about
well molecular biology drug design
basically if your system is made of
atoms and that's a lot around here
it is governed by the Schrodinger
equation and well let me stress again
that if you could solve this equation
you could basically answer every
question about those systems without
needing any prior knowledge without
needing any empirical data you just
could compute it from basic laws of
science of course this probably sounds a
bit good too good to be true and it
certainly is so let me let me quickly
show you what what the problem is what
you see here is an SI molecule it's
probably the simplest molecule one of
the simplest molecules you could
encounter it consists of two carbon
atoms which are those two black balls
here and
six hydrogen atoms here at the ends and
what you cannot see because they are
they are so fast is a cloud of 30
electrons which is moving quickly around
this molecule and basically lose it
together so what Shrinivas equation does
is that if you solve it it yields you
what is called the wave function and the
wave function basically describes the
state of this electron cloud that moves
around here and actually if you really
could solve Schrodinger's equation it
would give you an infinite series of
such wave functions where each describes
a different energy state of the molecule
but to make life simple today we are I'm
focusing on on what is called the ground
state which is the lowest energy state
of the molecule which is actually the
most interesting property most of the
time so this strange wave function
depends on the coordinates of all the
electrons in this electron cloud so for
30 electrons this makes 90 coordinates
in three-dimensional space so if you
would now go ahead and kind of naively
discretize this wave function and if you
would say use 20 grid points in each
coordinate direction you would need 8
times 20 to the power of 90 bytes to
store the function this sounds like an
awful large number so let me quickly
illustrate how large it is it's if you
would have some kind of hypothetical
future storage medium where you could
store one byte on each atom this is
probably the highest storage density
humanity can can ever hope to achieve
this would allow you to store a billion
petabytes on the volume of an SD card
enough for your holiday fall to say I
hope so how much volume would you need
of this medium to store the wave
function of this simple as a molecule if
you do the math you will end up with one
point six times ten to the 39th cubic
light-years so this is roughly very
roughly 1 million times the size of the
universe so this I think you can
rightfully call that big data of course
this is just to convince you that it's
it's never going to be practically to
really go that route and solve religious
equation directly for the wavefunction
so people have well found all sorts of
clever ways around it and all sorts of
clever approximations and I'm going to
talk about density functional theory or
DFDS physicists usually call it here
it's not the most accurate approximation
but it's it has become immensely popular
in the past few years in the past decade
because it offers a very very good
trade-off between accuracy and
computational effort to reach that kind
of accuracy it is based on two theorems
by by Pierre Homburg and worte Kuhn who
got awarded a Nobel Prize in Chemistry
in 98 for his findings together with
John popper who was the first guy who
made these calculations practical so in
in simple words the first theorem tells
you the density is special and the
density is something the electron
density is something you could compute
if you have the wavefunction and it
basically tells you if you look at a
certain point in space if you look there
what is the probability of finding any
electron there so it is a function in
one variable and it's a much much much
simpler object than the wave function
the wave function would need is these
millions of universes to store it well
the density might pull it down to say a
few hundred kilobytes to a few hundred
megabytes what this theorem tells you is
something extremely astonishing it tells
you that you can turn this relation
around and start from the density and
you have a unique way from that density
to calculate the wave function which
means that those two very different
objects contain the very same
information so everything that is
contained in this huge wave function is
also contained in the density in
principle this is one of those
mathematical existence theorems that
tells you it's in there but it doesn't
tell you how to get it out in even
simpler words it tells you everything
you might ever want to calculate about a
quantum mechanical system is contained
in a density alone the density is
everything you will ever
need and physicists like to put this in
more mathematical terms and say
everything is a function L of the
density and this is what gave the theory
its name now what makes it somewhat more
practical is the second theorem which
don't look at the slide it looks too
complicated it's what the second theorem
tells you is that also the energy is
something very special the energy of
course can only depend on the density
because everything depends on the
density and the second theorem tells you
if you would have a way to compute the
energy for a given density then the 1
density that gives you the smallest
energy is the ground state density you
are looking for so if you could compute
it this would give you a way to look for
the ground state density of course we
cannot compute it but at this point
people have found clever approximations
and instead of the real thing you are
minimizing the approximation and well in
the past say 50 years of density
functional Theory people have made huge
progress in in finding very good
approximation it's in this field to give
you a short idea on how much effort
these calculations are I compiled this
table here it's it's the simple if a
molecule you have seen would probably
take seconds and so this is something
you can do on your iPhone and take a few
megabytes of main memory at runtime
I recently did a calculation of a
fullerene this is a kind of a football
okay I'm in the United States I should
say a soccer ball of carbon atoms and it
took roughly four hours five hours on
one core and needed a few gigabytes so
this is a bit larger and the largest
calculations I've recently come across
is I didn't do that
that last one myself this was panning by
a Japanese group is a silicon nanowire
consisting of I think roughly 15,000
silicon atoms and 60,000 electrons and
the calculation consumed 1.1 billion
core hours and judging from the data I
gave in the paper probably needed a few
terabytes at one time so it can
get very demanding but simple systems
basically nowadays with today's
computers can be done even even on iPads
or iPhones so let me show you an example
what you can do actually let me skip to
the next example what you see here is a
benzene molecule you see that the
structure of the benzene molecule here
on the right side it's a ring of six
carbon atoms and six hydrogen atoms
around here and this poor guy has been
put in a strong magnetic field and what
you see here on the left hand side is
electric currents that get induced by
this applied magnetic field the reason
why we want to calculate this is is to
calculate nuclear magnetic resonance
spectra you you know NMR nuclear
magnetic resonance probably from from
hospital or from your doctor from this
NMR scans there it's it's your body that
gets subjected to this magnetic field
and the currents get induced in all the
molecules in your body and the reason
why one does it is that these currents
strongly depends obviously on the
chemical structure of the molecule so
different structure means different
currents and you can indirectly measure
them by because those currents in turn
induce a secondary magnetic field and
the positions of some of the atoms you
have isotopes that have a spin so this
is like a small little compass needle
and you can ticularly this company delay
do pulse and measure it's its resonance
frequency and this frequency gets
detuned depending on the magnetic field
there which again depends on the
currents which again depend on the
chemical structure of the molecule so in
this very indirect way you can conclude
back from from the output of the machine
to the chemical structure of the
molecule
in Indiana Mars Canada your doctors this
is used to have contrast between
different tissues but in analytical
chemistry this is used to really find
out what what substance it is and people
have used and compiled huge databases of
kind of empirical data that allows you
to
to conclude back to the structure and
there's a lot of empirical knowledge the
reason why we like to do with this is we
think it would be it would be nice if
you could solve the inverse problem by
by a computer by generating calculating
the the output and and then turning
things around and concluding from the
output of such a machine to the chemical
structure the other very different
example I wanted to show you here it is
is from semiconductor theory it's this
is this picture is a photo I took from a
publication it shows you semiconductor
so these are 500 nanometers here with
some electrodes on top and well I did a
short little kind of fun research
project on this what these electrons do
is they push electrons away so electrons
can only move freely in this this dark
gray area and people are interested in
what happens around around these dots so
having 50 in mathematica I well I first
edited a picture a bit and remove the
errors and the red dots because they are
not really part of the physical system
so electrons can move here so I used
Mathematica to turn this into a
black-and-white image so electrons can
now move in in the white part well I did
a bit of edge detection and and meshed
the remaining area and so because we are
just interested in what happens around
here I also removed these these wedges
down down here so I ended up with
something like this now okay if you we
also agreed on a kind of potential this
is a bit of empirical input here these
electrons might feel and stand well with
that input you can go ahead and do the
density functions here calculation in
Mathematica and the point here this is
very simple it's actually two
mathematical commands one is kind of
used to set up common things that you
can reuse for more calculations in the
end there is another mathematical
command just to start the calculation my
point here is that you don't need to be
an expert on density functional here
to do that this could be done by say an
experimental physicist also once you
have done the calculation you can use
Mathematica to to analyze your results
for let me skip that for instance this
this is the density which is as you have
probably guessed an important quantity
in density functional theory this plot
here shows you that the electrons are
really sitting at those two dots which
was not very clear from the outset but
there is a finite probability that
electrons might also spill out here yes
this is probably more interesting for
physicists you can using mathematical
you can now also make your simple nice
user interfaces to explore different
different aspects of the system so I
hope you like the example so just to
give you a flavor of what what we can do
so why would it be to choose Mathematica
to do that if you speak to physicists
this usually needs a bit of
justification because the traditional
languages are either Fortran or C++ and
the word traditional is probably not
strong enough you should say there are
two religions and basically one
motivation was that with automail a bit
of heresy now Intendant could be quite
fun the other reason was that I didn't
want this large monolithic kind of
simulation code but more more rapid
development environment to try out new
ideas so I'm in the lucky position that
I've been part of over time padding in
three different density function is here
we teams and I've been part in the
development of a Fortran whole of the
C++ code and now I did it in Mathematica
so I'd like to show you a simple
comparison but but please let me show
this disclaimer here this is I mean this
is anecdotal evidence it's not a
benchmark I'm showing you so don't don't
believe the numbers orders of magnitude
are probably significant but if ignore
factors of two the first question people
usually ask is is it fast enough
well this is
come on this is not fast enough what I
show you here is two results for a very
simple system we used to well to check
if the results are okay where the C++
code came in at 4.1 seconds and
Mathematica at 4.5 so this is
practically the same for this fullerene
calculation c++ took five and a half
hours Mathematica five hours 55 so this
is also practically the same because I
mean it could be the other way around if
you just tuned a few parameters it'd be
differently the type of efficiency I
usually mind more than the efficiency at
runtime is actually my time how long
does it take me in in developing the
thing so again this is a very rough
comparison this the Fortran code used
about needed about fifty thousand lines
of code just well for the numerical
simulation and talked about roughly
three person years to develop to give
you a kind of scale of comparing because
I mean the features of those codes don't
exactly overlap so do to give you a
scale to charge how how how many
features a code supports I've introduced
this percent scale where and normalize
the older Fortran code of at 100% so the
C++ code was 20,000 lines of code to one
and a half years to develop and it's
support basically eighty percent of what
what the Fortran code can do and
Mathematica the mathematical code is the
youngest one it has actually two parts a
finite elements package a small one
which consumed 860 lines of code but
this is this was done at Mathematica
nine and now Mathematica ten contains a
finite element package so this is some
going to be obsolete and the actual
actual density functional theory called
with 300 lines of Mathematica code so
this is it's really amazing how much you
can do with with just 300 lines of code
and it
roughly 70 hours to develop it so this
thing tells me I'm running out of time
so let me let me conclude by well but
trying to give you an idea what I'm up
to here the way these calculations are
traditionally performed is is that a
professor goes and finds a PhD student
and then applies for a grant to to
finance the PhD student and after some
years you pick up your results and I
think this is still fine if you do
calculations that really push the
boundaries of what we can do today but
my argument is that in the past 30 years
or so we have pushed the boundaries so
far that behind them there is a huge
realm of much simpler calculations that
that should be much more accessible to
maybe a public audience and actually the
the so-called chemical space this is the
space of all chemical compounds you
could form by by all the elements in the
periodic table is it's actually huge it
probably takes also a few million of
universes to store so there is no way of
compiling impurity data or measurement
data on all possible committee
structures but at least for simple to
medium structures this gives you a way
to actually compute the quantities you
want to know about dead structures and
what I would really like to see is that
in a few years I can go to do something
like this and go to Wolfram Alpha and
enter something like been seeing nuclear
magnetic resonance shift and Wolfram
Alpha comes back and tells me well there
is no database that contains what you
want to know but I did compute it for
you and this should at least work for
simple molecules if you come along with
your 60,000 electron silicon nanowire it
might probably say you need to buy a
more cloud credits to do that or
something like this so there is another
two minutes so thank you for your
attention